Paul I I have to tell you I I watching
this film from like the first frame out
I just kept thinking how classy and
money and elevated your taste level is
like what was your mood board for this
film as a filmmaker cuz your choices are
remarkable and just wonderful that's
very kind and flattering um I think um
uh I really wanted to make something
with enormous heart and I I love frank
cpra movies they're like such a
such a they always touch
me watch Mr Smith Goes to Washington a
hundred times and weep every time and
the ending always gets me It's a
Wonderful Life is is a wonderful movie
wonder which my uncle is in um Lionel
berrymore he plays Potter and he was in
a wheelchair in real life which is why
he's in a wheelchair in the film I had
no idea that's your uncle he's fantastic
thank you anyway what was your guys's
conversation to take on an iconic role
like what did you say to Timothy cuz
taking on Wonka is is is a thing I I I
felt very confident that he was going to
be great so for me I just I it was we
had a list of one and I just thought he
was extraordinary and I really wanted
him to do do the movie and I didn't want
to do the movie if he wasn't going to do
the movie so I think I was in uh seduced
mode well it seemed to have worked Kayla
can I ask like when you're coming into
this
what is it that what are what's on your
dream board for this well I I always
wanted to get a movie like this I'd
always I always wanted to get a movie
where I could sing and dance and like um
a big movie just like this how did you
know you could sing and dance how does
because I don't have a musical bone in
my body but I love music but I know my
limitations how do you all of a sudden
open your mouth and go I can sing well
my mom figured that out but I didn't
really like I don't think I really like
realized that I could sing I think I
just I don't know think I just sung just
the thing speaking of singing Hubert Dre
all I wna do is find a way
back love that was perfect it
was you you know s that sound sound that
sound that sound that sounded great no
yes I'm subtle and I can
sing he a boyfriend when you can hear
that you just need these three on a
couch oh my God that's not you were
carrying a tune last year I think you
described my singing as uh dogs or cats
dying or something and you're not wrong
Hubert but I was a second part to what I
said which was that although you
sometimes were what they I believe they
call a little pitchy you had some heart
and and a and a great voice and once the
machine had pitched you you sounded
brilliant whereas I could vaguely sing
in tune but you know this was meant to
be you know pop music and I sounded like
Julie Andrew is doing The Sound of Music
it was always rather enunciated and
boring well I just I love singing with
you and I not the chocolates again I
know
take Kayla and Paul have done okay
quickly
unwrap okay okay rapid fire what's on
your chocolate if you had to sumarize
your life right now with a song title
what song would it be you've never had
chocolate like this part
two done love it Hubert uh what's your
weirdest fear I I don't like Pines dogs
at all I'm terrified of them one of them
Savaged me as a child a dog yeah
it's quite odd to be mowed by creature
that small yeah but I was and uh I can't
even think about them so pineses they're
weird yeah what movie or TV show do you
wish you had a role in I wish you know I
would have loved to have been in Game of
Thrones oh yeah just something any
anything in game ofon
yeah a do like a DOI general you know I
mean would have been awesome Kayla
what's your chocolate site what's your
most annoying
habit I mean when I get nervous I guess
I like move a lot I mean I guess that's
not really annoy I don't
know H if that's your most annoying I
don't know you're Kaylor is not an
annoying person that's the thing she's a
very Charming person well what about you
Paul what does your chocolate say I have
tell us your favorite British slang word
and all I can think is Boozer do you
know what a boozer is I mean a drinker
yeah drinking place like an
establishment we're going to the Boozer
like a proper Pub oh oh gotcha okay I
thought AB Boozer was a person I all
right like a with a brown paper bag yeah
right staggering down the street right I
I want to thank you for this film I love
it so much I think you're all so
incredible in it thank you for putting
that out into the
[Music]
world